27 años después y un nuevo maleconazo la
unión de jóvenes comunistas reunió a
miles de personas este jueves en las
calles para mostrar apoyo al gobierno
del presidente miguel díaz canel lo
hicieron entre arengas a fidel castro- y
culpas al embargo estadounidense por la
grave situación que vive el país
caribeño
estoy acá con el pueblo cubano que está
confirmando que nada nos va a dilatar
nada base que nos hablan demos te vamos
a confirmar todo el tiempo que sea
necesario estas marchas son vistas como
una reacción a las protestas de hace
tres semanas las más grandes de las
últimas décadas contra el gobierno y la
gestión del cobi 19
cuba hasta inmersa en una grave crisis
económica de extrema escasez agravada
por la pandemia y las sanciones re
impuestas durante la presidencia de
donald trump las protestas del 11 y 12
de julio dejaron un muerto decenas de
heridos y centenares de detenidos un
contexto que recuerda al del 5 de agosto
de 1994 cuando dos años y medio después
de la disolución de la unión soviética
cuba sufría una enorme escasez de
alimentos combustibles y energía en
aquel día ante las protestas
fidel castro salió a las calles para
hablar con los manifestantes frente al
hotel de ville algo que este jueves ha
repetido el presidente díaz canel quien
salió a conversar con jóvenes en la
universidad de la habana así habló en su
red social a nuestros jóvenes hay que
escucharlos como las más importantes
personas que son además del disenso
político cuba se encuentra en el peor
momento de las pandemias con mil 159
casos por cada 100.000 habitantes es el
segundo país del mundo con mayor
incidencia